Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is going to be my new flash flashpoint
video in Justice League Easter eggs we
just got some big news about what's
going on with the flash movies so we'll
break it all down if you're nbew to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the videos will do a new Amazon giveaway
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave all your
predictions for the flash flashpoint
movie on the video so starting with the
big stuff first number five several news
sites have reported in the last couple
of days that Jeffrey Dean Morgan is
currently in the process of closing a
deal to star in the new flash movie as
the version of Thomas Wayne from Justice
League flashpoint
if you're not a big comic book reader or
you haven't seen any of the fan art of
him in the past few years that would
make him
flashpoint Batman
Bruce is dead, I watched him die
probably one of the
coolest alternate versions of Batman in
the multiverse from the comics and if
you didn't know Warner Brothers and the
last few directors to attempt to make a
flash movie the last couple of years
have all confirmed that they were doing
versions of the Justice League
flashpoint storyline for the plot of the
flash movie is one of the most famous
flash stories of all time one of the
most famous DC Comics stories of all
time so no big surprise that they would
want to attempt it with a flash movie
but Batman in the flashpoint timeline
isn't Bruce Wayne because in that
version of events Bruce is the only one
killed in Crime Alley by Joe Chill in
Thomas and Martha Wayne his parents were
the ones who survived and he gets his
own version of a Batman origin story
Martha Wayne becomes the flashpoint
version of the Joker being driven mad by
Bruce's death so flashpoint is meant to
be the darkest timeline outcome as a way
to twist the metaphorical knife in the
Flash's back for having dared to try and
cheat fate by using time-travel to try
and save his mother from being killed by
reverse-flash Jeffrey Dean Morgan is
known for playing very hardcore
characters most people think of the
comedian when they think of his comic
book characters he even took a picture
of himself wearing his comedian mask
from The Watchmen movie a while ago
there was a great Justice League
flashpoint animated movie DC did a long
time ago that all referenced throughout
this video along with Justice League
apocalypse war because that movie also
contained a second flashpoint event and
there's some similarities in the Justice
League apocalypse war movie to the
plans that Zack Snyder had for his
Justice League movies in sequels when
they were still doing a trilogy there
was going to be a version of a
flashpoint in Future Justice League
sequels where they tried to alter the
past to avoid dark side taking over the
earth so number four there are a lot of
questions about how this flashpoint
storyline in the flash movie is using
the Justice League movie in Batman's DC
EU story because as you all know Jeffrey
Dean Morgan played Thomas Wayne in
Batman V Superman lauren cohan played
Martha Wayne both actors from the
walking dead coincidentally they were
only in that opening scene depicting the
iconic Batman Crime Alley origin story
we all saw a version of that play out at
the end of the Joker movie too recently
they do a version of this and pretty
much every single new Batman franchise
when they reboot with a new actor
hopefully Matt Reeves finds a fresh way
of addressing it in the Batman movie
next year with Robert Pattinson because
I don't think we need to see this scene
exactly like this again right after
seeing it in the Joker movie but if
they're even thinking about using
Jeffrey Dean Morgan Thomas Wayne as
flashpoint Batman the movie also has to
address Ben Affleck's Batman in some way
the whole point in doing flashpoint
Batman is the payoff scene with Bruce
Wayne Batman at the end where he finally
gets to read his father's message again
after not having heard from him since
his death when he was a child this is
that scene
yes, a gift
this is my father's handwriting
that scene packs so much of a punch is
such a huge payoff for the Batman
character so you can't just do Thomas
Wayne Batman without having some kind of
Bruce Wayne bookend at the end of the
movie but there hasn't been any recent
talk of Ben Affleck having a cameo scene
in the flash movie so hopefully they can
get him to come back for a cameo scene
the only Batman stuff that we know that
he's coming back for right now is just
to do additional voiceover dialogue for
the Justice League Snyder cut that
they're releasing next year but that's
very different from him doing a
full-blown cameo scene in a future DC
movie number 3 as for a lauren cohan
Joker there hasn't been any talk of
including her version of the character
and when the flash movie producers said
that they're doing a different version
of the Justice League flashpoint
storyline they were saying that it would
be much smaller and self-contained
than the original story the original
flashpoint was a huge Justice League
universe spanning story featuring all of
the Justice League characters including
Hal Jordan Green Lantern as well as most
of the other major DC comic book
characters DC Comics used the event to
reboot their entire comic book universe
to the new 52 the problem with doing
that in the movies as most people have
realized is that owner to do a comic
book accurate version you'd have to make
it a full-blown Justice League sequel
and it would be less of a flash movie at
that point it would cost two hundred
fifty million dollars in right now
Warner Brothers is just way too scared
to make a Justice League sequel right
away I've already done a couple of
videos about that patty Jenkins revealed
that behind the scenes their new movie
strategy is all about just doing solo
movies one at a time for the characters
smaller stuff building up to another
Justice League way down the road which i
think is the right way to do it so
smaller flashpoint just means that most
of the alternate versions of the
characters will probably see will be
flashed specific characters with maybe a
few bigger Justice League crossover
characters Thomas Wayne Batman would be
one of those the flash movie producers
also confirmed recently this cyborg
would be featured during the movie she
didn't say how much cyborg would be in
it only that he would be in there
somewhere
the flash spends most of his time
studying the Speed Force at STAR Labs
doing research cyborg father runs STAR
Labs in the DC EU so it's a natural fit
also in that original version of Zack
Snyder's Justice League sequels in one
of the movies the fly
teams up with cyborgs to crack the
science of time travel together using
the Speed Force so that he can go back
and warn Batman flashpoint is a time
travel story so it's easy to justify
cyborg helping the flash make necessary
calculations number two the Justice
League Snyder cut that's coming out next
year won't change a lot about what
they're doing with the flash movie and a
machete from the it movies is the one
that's doing the flash movie now he
pretty much has free rein to do what he
wants with the character he can include
as much or as little of the Justice
League Snyder cut stuff as he wants I
haven't heard anything about him having
conversations with Zack Snyder about his
original vision for how the flash
character would develop through his
Justice League sequels the Snyder cut is
supposed to be over four hours long so
I'm assuming that even though they're
not going to be doing that Justice League
sequels they'll at least address some of
that flash time-travel scene from Batman
V Superman in some of their
conversations even if they don't spend a
lot of time dealing with that so going
into the flash movie he will have
already time traveled at some point but
they'll have to have a funny way of
explaining it because technically based
on the rules of time-travel this version
of the flash will not have experienced
that yet so because a lot of flashpoint
is based on mistakes that the flash
makes I think that'll all just play into
the movie the ending of the Justice
League Snyder cut will be different from
the theatrical cut but for the most part
emotionally the flash will be in the
same place so going into the beginning
of the events of the Flash movie Barry's
father is still in jail framed for his
mother's death by reverse-flash they
haven't cast a reverse flash yet I know
everybody has a lot of fan cast the
actor who plays homelander on the boys
would make a fantastic reverse flash
So I went back to Vogelbaum, and
I managed to squeeze the truth out of him.
The real truth.
he's the main villain of flashpoint
so it's a safe bet that they'll do him
right out of the gate but they haven't
confirmed officially that they will do
reverse flash there was a version of the
movie at one point that heavily featured
the core flash rogues led by Captain
Cold I don't know if they're going to be
featured in the new movie but it's a
safe bet that they'll at least be a
reference and I'm assuming if the movie
does well enough they'll continue with
Ezra Miller in the sequels I know
there's a lot of questions about him
just because it's been pretty quiet
recently but as far as we know he is
still playing the flash until told
otherwise the number one big question
everyone
has what about changing Batman in the DCEU
and how they going to handle Batman in
the next Justice League if they ever get
around to making it most of what Matt
Reeves has said the last year implies
that he isn't really thinking about any
kind of giant Justice League story line
or a crossover or overarching universe
spanning storyline with his new Batman
trilogy he's just thinking about Batman
characters in Gotham City and it sounds
like Warner Brothers doesn't have any
concrete plan for how to handle Batman
in the next Justice League movie or real
plan for another Justice League movie at
all right now they're just going to wait
and see how the next round of movies
goes then they'll come back to the table
and figure it out so if there's any DC
EU Batman at the end of the flash movie
to bookend things I think it would have
to be Ben Affleck's Batman and then that
would be his actual final appearance as
the character it would be the best way
to send his character off with this
scene here of him reading his father's
message now that doesn't solve the
problem of explaining new Batman in the
next Justice League but that movie is
probably at least five years away from
getting made so it's not really worth
worrying about too much right now but if
we hear any more news about that of
course I'll do a video post all your
video requests in the comments below
congratulations to the one you're the
giveaway winner from my last big DC
video please email me on the about page
of my channel so I can get your contact
details
everyone click here for my Justice
League Snyder cut trailer video and
click here to learn about the new
version of the Joker that they're
supposedly going to introduce in the new
Batman movies thank you so much for
watching everyone stay safe
I'll see you you guys tonight!